estas imágenes granuladas de drones
publicadas por el Ministerio de defensa
ruso son según Afirma Moscú el comienzo
de la contraofensiva ucraniana en la
provincia de donniesk el humo que se
puede ver en los campos serían
divisiones de tanques ucranianos siendo
destruidos y esto el momento de un
ataque directo una operación de cinco
frentes separados que habría fracasado
según Moscú el enemigo no logró su
cometido no tuvo éxito como resultado de
las acciones capaces y calculadas del
grupo de fuerzas en el este el ejército
ucraniano sufrió pérdidas de más de 250
personas 16 tanques tres vehículos
blindados de transporte de tropas y 21
vehículos blindados
no ha habido comentarios de kiev El
mensaje del Ministerio de defensa
ucraniano en este vídeo publicado en las
redes sociales el domingo es una campaña
de silencio advirtiendo de que la
especulación podría ayudar al enemigo
horas antes el presidente zenensky
declaró un periódico que su país ya está
preparado para reconquistar el
territorio ocupado por Rusia afirmó que
no para de reunirse con los aliados de
La otan para exigirles más armamento y
defensas aéreas y añadió que no podían
esperar meses
en las últimas semanas Rusia se ha
encontrado defendiendo su propio
territorio con múltiples ataques en
velerot una región fronteriza clave para
las líneas de suministro dos grupos
paramilitares rusos que apoyan a Ucrania
se atribuyen la responsabilidad de los
ataques contra instalaciones y
energéticas y depósitos de combustible
entre otros objetivos los analistas
describen esos ataques como operaciones
de configuración ucranianas que intentan
crear las condiciones en el campo de
batalla y más allá para que ofrezcan la
mejor oportunidad de ganar sobre el
terreno si la contraofensiva ha
comenzado o está a punto de hacerlo
Puede que no quede claro durante algún
tiempo